[Música]
um dia a gente falar sobre bullying
virtual
eis que nesse tema porque além de muitas
pessoas sofrerem com o bullying virtual
é um tema muito atual e é com ele que
ocorre com muita freqüência
atualmente todo mundo anda com um
eletrônico então as chances de você
sofre bullying são grandes
eu hein e eu queria aprofundar um pouco
nesse tema para descobrir como é o
bullying ele começa não é não passo
explicou que o nível do acidente se
explicar o que é o próprio bullying
o bullying em inglês ele deriva de
bonito ou seja nem tão todas as formas
de condutas agressivas físicas ou
verbais que causando dor e angústia a um
eventual não é nada mais nada menos que
o bullying cotidiano ou seja aquele
bonito a gente vem acontecendo
as únicas diferenças é que como já diz o
nome o bullying virtual acontece nos
ambientes virtuais e muitas e algumas
vezes nós não sabemos quem está fazendo
bem virtual pois está usando uma conta
falsa logo do gênero
o bullying ele acontece quando alguém
passou de outro game seja por um motivo
bom negativo pode ser que uma pessoa
muito inteligente porque ela não tem uma
aparência tão aceita na sociedade
bom o bullying como eu já disse acontece
em ambientes virtuais ou seja dentro das
linhas pode acontecer nas redes sociais
e até em jogos online
no caso das redes sociais o bullying
virtual ele pode acontecer de várias
maneiras
ele pode acontecer por um comentário de
uma foto vídeo ou pode acontecer até
mesmo costuma fazer o vídeo xingando
outra pessoa para mandar uma mensagem
para ela existem várias maneiras
no caso dos jogos acontece pelo xeque as
pessoas conversam entre si ou pelo
microfone bom trampolim acontecer mas
precisamos de alguns personagens
pensem um pouco talvez nem saibam quem
eles são
aqui estão eles nós temos o agressor é a
testemunha ea vítima
às vezes a vítima ela está sofrendo
bullying por um motivo que nem a nem
ela sabe às vezes a pessoa que está
fazendo bullying há simplesmente não
gosta dela mas às vezes a vítima possa
alguma coisa tão absurda na internet é
como se ela tivesse pedindo pra sofreu
bullying
bom depois temos o agressor às vezes o
agressor ele ficou net une virtual como
uma brincadeira de mau gosto na cabeça
dele era só uma brincadeira ele não
imaginava que a vítima se sentiria tão
mal mas também às vezes o agressor e ele
comenta algo meio maldoso mas ele não
tava com a intenção de brincar mas
também não tem a intenção de fazer o mal
ele já queria expor sua opinião mesmo
não sendo tão boa
estes dois casos são fáceis de lidar são
fáceis de esclarecer mas às vezes tem
aqui é aquele agressões que realmente
está querendo fazer o mal
bom a testemunha se você parar pra
pensar
ela pode ser mais importante desses
personagens ela pode ser qualquer um de
vocês essa peça platéia ela pode ter o
poder de acabar como bullying virtual
às vezes ela vê o bullying e pensa que
aquilo é só mais uma coisa normal
acontecendo não precisa fazer nada
às vezes ela vê aquilo para e pensa
calma senão é bom eu vou falar com
alguém e fala para o responsável a
autoridade
às vezes há a testemunha ri da situação
às vezes ela pensa e não tem a ver
comigo não preciso me preocupar e às
vezes ela ainda compartilha o virtual
fazendo o que o agressor que é a atenção
bom o bolinho ele não faça nada mais
nada menos que 12 tristeza mas não é
aquela dor de cabeça é uma dor profunda
que podem acabar levando a doenças muito
sérias como depressão e ansiedade que
podem acabar levando ao suicídio que
normalmente ocorre entre jovens e
adolescentes
bom pra você a parte boa como se evita o
bullying virtual
existem várias maneiras algumas delas
estão aqui se você sabe de alguém que
comete bullying virtual faz o possível
para a pessoa parar tem que explicar
para ela o mal que está causando
se você sofre bullying virtual conhece
alguém que sofre sair para um
responsável da autoridade porque e que
pode ajudar muito bom
não posso qualquer coisa na internet e
nunca nunca compartilhe o libertador
depois você vai estar
vendo o que o agressor quer que você
faça no caso das redes sociais se você
tem uma conta privada a chance de você
sofrer bullying virtual são muito
pequenas
pois só quem você quer que vejam que
você posta conseguir mas a partir do
momento que você deixa de ter uma conta
privada onde todos podem ver o que você
posta
você precisa ter o dobro de cuidado e
atenção pois você pode começar a sofrer
bullying virtual olha num disquete olhos
bom como diz como disse o presidente da
do facebook o futuro ele é privado
bom espero que vocês tenham entendido e
tenham gostado e muito obrigada pela sua
atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]